here at the scouting combine in
indianapolis joining us now a man who is
entering
lucky number 13. wow year 13. damn
you're that old i know general manager
thomas dimitrov thomas welcome back i
always appreciate being here this is one
of my highlights as you know
i heard you say that right over there i
was on fire
i mean this is great i know because you
know we get a chance to really talk
about all the things that are on your
mind and and uh we usually have good
conversations about it i feel like every
year it's the same question can you
believe it's been x number of years but
i mean to make it 13 years that is a
rarity in the nfl general managers
especially like you burn bright short
period of time and then back to being a
scout again for the most part how do you
explain the fact that you've made it as
long as you have running the falcons
well look i i do have a strong feeling
about that because i think it's it's
everything you obviously have to be you
know in my position you have to be an
adept uh you know co-team builder right
with the head coach i'm a big believer
in that relationship being really really
important i said this from way back when
i looked at guys like marty
schottenheimer and aj smith two really
good football man at loggerheads and
before i even got this job i said
whatever i do
the relationship that i have with a head
coach is paramount yes of course i
answered to the owner and now in our
setting which we can talk about you know
to rich mckay as arthur's designee but
the relationship that i have with our
head coach is so important it was with
mike smith it is with dan quinn now work
on that all the time that is really
important to understand the lines to
talk about things recently interestingly
enough yeah 13 years now going into my
13th year i've had a lot of discussions
about when you gauge the importance and
the the honesty within a relationship
you can say that about any i'm not going
to wax about our own poetic about our
own relationships yeah when you can be
honest with your partner right
that's very very important it's about
the delivery right you can't just fly
off throwing f-bombs you know
i tell him he's an ass all the time and
he appreciates it but the importance of
that is what i'm saying and making you
avoid things festering right if you're
not honest in relationship you get
resentment you get jealousy you get
festering and then you get split
loyalties where when things go sideways
you say it's his fault he says it's your
fault and somebody wins and somebody
loses whereas your approach is we're
always on the same team here we're
joined at the hip basically we either
both rise together or we both fall
together and i'm not saying you bs your
partner at all right like i've had
people tell me some people and i won't
mention names in this league who have
been in my position who have said you
need you need a contentious relationship
to get the most out of the relationship
vehemently agree about with that i
believe you have to have a working
relationship
again back to honesty again making sure
that you're talking about what's on your
mind is really important to the fester
side but i will say not only on the
relationship side but on moves that
you're making or moves that are
happening in the coaching side dan and i
have a really good honest relationship
with that whether he thinks hey scout is
not doing the job he's doing or i think
there's a coach that needs to be
adjusted we have great conversations i
think that's vital well all right so
take us behind the curtain a little bit
because it's interesting and i knew that
was always kind of your philosophy
you're a very good communicator that way
but all right just say we're getting
closer to the draft here and i'm just
gonna say say you're thinking about
taking a defensive end or whatever are
you gonna sit down
with dan at some point and kind of like
go like hey here's the here's the three
guys i think we could draft at this pick
right here and listen to his two cents
about it i mean how much dialogue do you
guys have yeah so we're we work very
well together in that in that setting of
course because we've always believed
like we're going to reach out we're a
very collaborative organization we we
involve the scouting staff and the
coaching staff together they work
together a lot we've seen it time and
again in nfls where there's this stupid
chasm quite honestly between it's about
all of us coming together in the end dan
and i sit down and we decide where it's
going to be you know in the very end i
want it to be a co co-decision right
we've talked if it's if we're ever
completely at odds on a player we'll
continue to convince each other and if
we don't convince each other and we're
both not in then we'd say we'd move on
that's a that's kind of a nice smooth uh
way to package it yeah but the reality
is we do listen to each other and we
talk about it and we try to get to the
bottom of why one or the other believes
in a certain player
with us it never gets contentious or
heated we may we may disagree right i
just think there's a respect for each
other in our roles dan really respects
where i am and what my my sort of um
art is and and i respect his and i think
that's really important for us yeah i
remember the old game show will the real
so and so please stand up remember that
to tell the truth well the real falcons
please stand up one in seven or six and
two which team is the real team i get it
it frustrates you guys i mean again i
you two in particular i mean amongst a
number of people obviously i get it yeah
i've listened and i've heard not maybe i
should be telling your fan base my fan
base
but i appreciate it and i understand
over the years you this isn't just i get
it i mean sometimes i i think about that
very thing and believe me i know that
arthur blank does where are we with this
and why is that and i've said before too
okay so we're seven to nine this year
seven and nine allows dan and i to
really hone in and
thank god you know arthur retained us
and we're in a spot i think it's a
really good good move of course and i
think um to be able to sit down and talk
about all that has gone awry right
sometimes they're small things sometimes
they're bigger things sometimes they're
moves sometimes there are coaching
elements that need to be adjusted we
have spent a lot of time on that and i
think we're in a spot where we are
pressure testing so i know that's the
end vogue word now but it is what we
need to really talk about what needs to
be adjusted we do believe that we have a
talented roster we do believe we have a
very good football coach and a very good
leader we believe that we're team team
building with a thoughtful approach
back to we've talked about this
accountability discipline
you know passion consistency those are
all things that are really important and
those are things that we're going to
continue to need to get out of our
football players to be a more consistent
and you know what you say will the real
falcons step up well you got so much
talent i mean i think we see the talent
on your football team i mean we know
there's real super bowl potential with
it yeah i feel like you've been ravaged
by injuries the last two years
especially last year where i mean it
makes life really tough and that's
probably it's why you started out one in
seven
did you do you guys dive into that too
this offseason a little bit like
training wait wait wait yes all that
what a great point yes because we do
look at that we look at the injury
situation don't we can't talk about it
publicly you can't use it as an excuse
right that said we do we look at our
program we're looking at our athletic
performance model right now i mean we're
in the middle of what a lot of teams
have done and i don't know where you
guys are on in this line but
in you know rd's by the way that's the
end vogue thing you don't call them
nutritionists anymore right sports rds
are a big thing in the nfl and most
teams have full-time rds yeah what's our
d what's our decision registered
dietitian okay so now you're fancy it's
kind of like you know you don't say give
me a better give me give me a better
time give me a better title and you pay
me more i like hey exactly i got i had
one gm call me back and tell me about
what he was paying his rd and he said
i'm coming back as an rd i'm going to be
in great shape
i'm going to eat well in this gm thing
when it's time to move on the reality is
we're looking at all that to make sure
that we have things in place and that is
one of the areas on the ap model side of
things let's how do we keep our guys
healthy keep our guys on the field you
can't have your your stud roster and
they're not on the field that's
obviously basic math yeah so it's
important we do discuss everything yeah
well i mean i find that to be one of
your challenges a little bit right now
because you guys are so super talented
and of course you've had to pay julio
with matt ryan and grady jared and you
got all these other guys how do you
how do you work depth like that
sometimes like you know that's that's to
me where i look at it and just go man
it's hard at times when you have
superstars at certain key positions and
then building some backups behind it
well interestingly enough to segue into
what was a big question last year okay
we went out drafted 2019 to be our
starters right and we brought in two
free agents that we had big expectations
with jamon brown and james carpenter as
guys that had experience we were
bringing those experienced guys in the
yeah so no matter what we were not going
to be in the situation where we were the
year before we thought it was going to
be the best five right even if we paid
more for some of the free agent
acquisitions right one of them was going
to be sitting off it ended up being that
way and there was some inconsistency
there but as you both know you can't
just go out in on the street midway
through the season and find players that
can be
solid starters i'm not saying top end
but just to find a guy off the street
that can be a starter and step in is
that's complicated yeah right in today's
world 13th year for you 13th year for
matt ryan he was the first round pick
when you joined the team in 2008 when do
you start thinking about
the next quarterback i mean how deep
into his career before you have a
serious
thought conversation plan for the next
franchise guy yeah i think you're i
think it's important to bring that that
question up when you especially when you
have what we consider an elite
quarterback and we continue to grow with
matt um i think it's important you have
to make sure as again as team builders
and the owner you have to think about it
we just we just knocked off a contract
that was 30 million a year for someone
it as you can imagine for us it's tough
to step back and think wow we're we're
going to be looking for you know next
waves of this in the next i don't know
how many years i think it's important so
i think you're we're always looking i
had mentioned recently what's important
for me as well is not just because we
have matt ryan am i not keeping my my my
evaluation skills on quarterbacks like i
need to make sure that i'm always
working that and not that i bury it for
12 plus years right it's really
important for me to always look at
quarterbacks so we are always looking at
quarterbacks i will say and you can
imagine this you're sitting there
potentially projecting to be in the top
four or five at one time in the season
you know when there was all that of
course your mind starts spinning in a
lot of a lot of ways because those teams
that are there that don't necessarily
need a quarterback and that's usually
rare right how do they pass up on a
quarterback even for the future yeah
sure yeah that is that that is a good
one okay while we're on the the combine
okay there's a lot of new things this
year i am interested in this i love to
hear this this total just out of left
field question
who's like the freakiest guy you ever
evaluated all your years new england
atlanta who's like that one workout
where you just went i just can't believe
what i just saw like is it gideon
clowney jumping over nine bags in south
carolina workout like just one just give
me a tidbit well i think those freaky
athletes are the ones and i'm this is a
little self-serving yeah but julio jones
i've never seen someone as powerful and
explosive and as naturally athletic as
as that that player and obviously it's
it's one of the things that we believe
that strongly i would agree i was on the
field for the national championship game
texas alabama
and i remember seeing him run the first
round and i went what yeah that's julio
jones i couldn't get over the size and
how he's moving so he made the big move
to get julio jones 2011. that was the
year when the draft came before free
agency because of the lockout
we've been asking guys about this i mean
do you ever think about how different
the world would be if it was like
basketball where you have the draft and
then you have free agency on a regular
basis well i think about it often i
think about how where we would be with
it i mean there's complicated sides to
both of it and right now i mean we love
that we're able to utilize you know
ideas and juxtapose the the free agent
talent potential free agent talent with
the draft class oh there's no question
we would we would be spun out i'd be
talking to my
close friends guys like rc buford a lot
more believe me about you know sort of
logistics and how you're going to
approach something like that if we were
ever in that spot i'll be interested to
see if that ever happens again
yeah i know i i sometimes wonder if it's
not the smarter way or it would be
easier for you guys to team build that
way that's where i always come back to
it because you go to the draft okay you
hopefully get what you want but then oh
now we have these needs we need to fill
but i guess that would drive up player
prices as well too which could be scary
i think there's probably the other side
of it with you know your player union
right
i mean they're going to always wonder if
the draft was first how is that going to
affect you know how's it going to affect
the rank order right some guys are going
to make a lot more money because
it's going to be addressed and all of a
sudden that guy's value goes through the
roof but guys want to get paid yes you
don't want to wait until may to get paid
you want to get paid in march you know
what though and
we're not going to go down the cba
rabbit hole but the league can start the
new year whenever they want and we saw
the draft come before free agency during
the lockout i mean if they keep talking
and talking and extending they've
already extended the franchise tag
window they can do whatever they want
they can push free agency into march or
may rather if both sides agree that's
the right way to go so get ready maybe
you'll get to do the draft before free
agency again this year who knows wow it
will be interesting to see how we work
through all that i'll leave that up to
rich mckay and all the smart people in
the league who are dealing with all this
right now well thomas it's great as
always to get a chance to talk to you
congratulations on 12 years 13 on the
way and hopefully we see you back here
again as you get ready to go into your
number 14 hopefully we'll still be
employed to do it always oh we'll be
here always great he may be here i'm
going to start i'm going to start
listening to his podcast just don't
don't do a lot more f-bombs and things
like that aaron rodgers would say don't
waste your time listening to that crap
what the hell are you talking about
thank you
thanks man appreciate you guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports